the Joe Rogan experience and with Kobe
as well I mean II you know that fight
was a lot more personal than a lot of
people think you know obviously with the
you know the the whole situation with my
my dad and him saying whatever he said
and and I know he like people say
certain things and Connor's a master at
this to try to get you off your game to
try to make you to rattle you make you
mad enough to where you come out you're
just crazy you know fighting them into
where you could be the best conditioned
athlete you can get in there and get an
adrenaline dump you look like you
haven't trained a date you know hmm
and I knew that's what they would like
I'm not stupid I knew what that's what
these guys are trying to do especially
him he was trying to do but I was he
gonna play into that he was had a very
steady pace it was very interesting you
could see that when you're fighting like
right away in the first round first of
all his pace is [ __ ] crazy
I mean that guy throws a lot of volume
but you you had you could tell that you
were not gonna blow your water early now
you were fighting very measured very
disciplined and you were throwing a lot
of front kicks to the body man that
front kick to the body is nasty yeah I
mean not you know just looking at his
style stylistically and matching Moke
with mine like I could have came in
there we would have wrestled yeah
everyone thought they just gonna wrestle
each other you know but did you think
that was possible that he's gonna try to
wrestle with you more
mm-hm you know there was a possibility
of him trying to wrestle but I knew that
he was worried about my wrestling
because everyone Tyron was a two-time
all-american tired
Tyron did better than him in Division
one wrestling better accolades and we
saw what happened with that fight so I
knew he was worried about me wrestling
me taking him down because if I take you
down you're not getting up unless I let
you up so I knew he was worried about
that but then they came a moment in the
fight to where we just looked at each
other and it was just like no not today
let's do it let's do it and and I was
fully aware I was fully prepared to bang
it out with him it was very surprising
because it really did turn out to be
basically a kickboxing fight
yeah I mean that was yeah we just we
just looked at each other and was just
like all right let's just do it mano a
mano let's go you know there's not gonna
be wrestling tonight so let's do it man
it could you the two you guys together
depending on how the rest of the
division stacks up because it's just
such a [ __ ] talented division there's
so much talent in that division there's
so many good fighters but depending on
how everything plays out you guys could
have two or three fights easily we'll
see yeah I mean we'll see first of all I
want to see how he bounces back from
that because like I said there was a lot
that went into that fight he said a lot
he did a lot like getting all that
weight on having all that weight on your
shoulders saying all the things that you
said ruffling all the feathers that you
ruffled and then coming out and and he
took a beating from the fans after that
like the backlash that he took oh yeah
it was was I don't know if you saw some
of the [ __ ] that was online like he took
a humungous oh I'm sure and and
rightfully saw I mean you that's the
game yeah that's the game that's the
game you want to talk crazy [ __ ] then
they're gonna I mean that the reason why
they're tuning into the fight so so many
of them yeah is because of all the crazy
[ __ ] you've talked yeah so naturally if
he loses all the people that were
rooting for you like yeah I knew it yeah
so I want to see how he bounces back
from all that because he's never had to
do it before psychologically yeah yeah
he's never had to do it before he's
never had to talk all that [ __ ] then go
in there and get you your mouth shut
literally and it's literally it's gonna
be interesting to see like who they
match him up with you know I mean who do
they I mean he's got possibilities oh
yeah if I mess with all yeah for sure
you know he can fight Maspeth all it
used to be boys right yeah they used to
be boys you should be training partners
and there's videos online of them I mean
you see what he was doing it mess a lot
early on like you know like there's
videos online with with with that of and
then it's like he can fight tyron
woodley like Tyron wins this fight like
I think they both fight for the number
one contender mm-hmm you know so it's it
is what it like the possibilities are
endless for them because there's so many
guys that want to catch
yeah so many guys in the division but I
don't think so a lot of guys in the
division can kick his ass right you know
so it's he's got he's you know he's got
possibilities he can he could fight guys
and it's also possible that he can learn
from that fight with you and come back a
better fighter that is possible so we
don't know how much it's gonna take out
of him but it is possible that he could
come from that me that will has ain't
[ __ ] crazy fine and that was the first
really crazy fight that he's experienced
other than one submission loss that he
had in the UFC where he had a he had an
injured rib he had to take the fight was
that Worley Alves or they have it yeah
so when you when you see him next then
we'll get a we'll get an understanding
or yeah but the thing though is uh
there's just certain guys you can't beat
I don't know what it is or why it is but
there's just certain guys that you
cannot be and I think I'm that guy that
he's just not gonna beat I will not
allow myself to lose to him do you think
if you had two good hands so if your
hand wasn't hurt it would have been a
different fight you left it I heard him
I think I heard him earlier but hats off
to him he's a tough guy I don't take
anything away from he fought a very good
fight that had to be the most honest
mine the most I've ever been hit ever
yeah he was hitting me he was touching
me and and he was I was never really
hurt bad but they were stinging shots
like they stung me a couple of like this
mother he's touching me
touching me but at no point that I I was
like I'm gonna come forward I'm gonna
hurt him he's a [ __ ] swinger man I
mean he he throws a lot of shots to his
volume is incredible but that had to be
the most satisfying to you it was when I
when I got back to the hotel and I and I
sat there and just I mean it was like
and I just posed by myself cuz I like to
decompress and I'm just like we got it
done I mean all this [ __ ] that this guy
said even my dad was you know like like
go take care of business you know and to
know that I went in there and I and I
did take care of business it was
extremely satisfying and it didn't hurt
when I freaking I mean a surplus of like
celebrities crazy celebrity
thank you very good well that whole
magazine on this guy you know you attach
yourself the whole magazine and you know
there's a lot of people it'll support
you because of that
yeah man there's so many like if you
fall down there's so many they just
can't wait to piss on you and kick you
oh man yeah it's a such a polarizing
position that he took he did but uh you
know I'm friends with the chump now you
were saying that you were gonna go visit
the White House and you tell me about
the body because I'm gonna do it yeah
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna go to the
White House but you also talked about it
dollars oh yeah I picked up the book and
uh you know initially was like okay cuz
this guy tried to troll me during our
press conference was trolling me like he
sat there while I was talking he was
reading the book and pretending like he
was reading the book yeah and um and
then I'm at the airport and I'm like oh
there's the book and I'm like [ __ ] it
I've got time today and I was rolling
them and I die by the book I'm like
screw it I'm gonna buy this book so I
actually buy the book
and and I take the screenshot and I and
I posted it the reaction for fans after
that it was it was views ridiculous
Donald Trump jr. reach out and actually
yeah yeah I actually you know messages
back
[Laughter]
but uh yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious
message you know and I don't know the
Trump's personally so I you know I can't
go out there and like oh I'm bashing
them just because this idiot was
attaching himself to them you know I'll
I look forward to meeting them and you
know actually talking to them listen
that would be a great moment for you to
bring that title to the White House
despite of all the [ __ ] yeah and
just let everybody know do you rise
yeah I mean I who would ever imagine
that I you know coming from the village
in Africa that I did you know and
getting to this point and actually going
in there to a White House
[Applause]